i've been asked this question quite
often so i'm going to do a video on it
what is the best
non-toxic
vegetable wash okay well the answer is
hydrogen peroxide let me explain what's
unique about hydrogen peroxide is that
it's h2o2 and it breaks down into water
and oxygen in our body actually makes it
our immune cells called phagocytes
actually make hydrogen peroxide as a
defense mechanism that's one of the
weapons that they use to kill off
pathogens okay
so the unique thing about hydrogen
peroxide is that it can kill off
microbes
and
it can remove
to a very large degree the chemicals
that kill off microbes like insecticides
fungicides herbicides and pesticides so
side means kill kill insects kill
funguses kill weeds
kill pests so hydrogen peroxide has the
ability to degrade and get rid of the
chemicals as well as the microbes the
problem with being exposed to these
poisons
is that they're fat soluble and they get
locked into our fat cells into our
organs
into our neurological tissue and our
brain
and even if you're doing organic
vegetables they still use some form of
pesticide or herbicide or fungicide it's
obviously not as toxic but sometimes
they use certain things so hydrogen
peroxide is a really good solution there
are other things you can use but i like
hydrogen peroxide because
it breaks down into
water and oxygen now the thing you need
to know about hydrogen peroxide is you
have food grade and you have regular
hydrogen peroxide i don't recommend
getting the regular hydrogen peroxide
that would be something that do sell at
the drugstore the problem with that is
they add stabilizers and probably about
roughly around four chemicals that to
help stabilize hydrogen peroxide and
those
are toxic and so we don't want those
residues on our food so you want to get
food grade
but the thing about hydrogen peroxide is
it's very unstable
so it doesn't last a long time so if you
actually buy hydrogen peroxide it may
last six months then eventually breaks
out into water in oxygen now when you
buy the food grade sometimes it comes in
35
concentration
you'd want to get the one that actually
is three percent because 35 percent is
very very very concentrated so you'd
have to dilute that and then dilute it
again before using it in this wash so if
you just buy the three percent it's
going to be a lot easier then you're
going to dilute this
by a ratio of one-fourth of a cup of
food-grade hydrogen peroxide to one
gallon of water okay and then you can
soak your vegetables in there for about
20 minutes and then you can dry them out
and you can store them in the
refrigerator now hydrogen peroxide can
be used for a lot of different things a
mouthwash that can be used to help
remove tartar because it kills biofilms
okay that's that's plaquing on your
teeth some people use it as a deodorant
and of course i'm talking about
diluting it first okay not a higher
concentration you're going to burn your
skin
you can use it as a disinfectant let's
say for example you want to clean your
counter or cooking surfaces it's great
for that it's good for ear infections
sore throats you can gargle with it acne
athlete's foot and the list goes on and
on and on like i said before hydrogen
peroxide is is a very good thing to use
because when you apply it correctly it
can be very non-toxic and your body
makes it it gets rid of microbes and the
chemicals that actually kill microbes
you know when people have an insect
problem or some
i don't know like ant problem or
they call a local company that comes out
and then
sprays either the inside of their house
or the outside of their house and a lot
of people don't even think twice of
what's happening they're actually
spraying these deadly chemicals and
they're usually in this fully protected
suit spraying this chemical inside your
house or outside your house
and these are poisons and they can be
carcinogens and a lot of people do it
and they don't even think twice so the
next time you actually consider doing
that i would find out what type of spray
they're using and you do the research do
a really good deep dive and find out
what they're spraying to make sure that
you want that around your house because
yes it will kill insects but it can
linger for months and months and months
before it breaks down plus your pet gets
it on their fur they bring it in the
house and then it gets on you there are
some very very natural uh good non-toxic
things to use
if you have pests around your house or
in your garden neem oil is a really good
one you can use diluted vinegar you can
use castile soap diluted one teaspoon in
a quart of water works really really
good this helps dissolve the membrane of
the microbe you can also use
diatomaceous earth and this is a really
good non-toxic way of killing microbes
around your house so anyway i wanted to
give you this quick non-toxic vegetable
wash that you can make very very
inexpensively now since we're on the
topic of poisons you may want to watch
this video on how the liver
deactivates or dismantles
poisons from your body right here
you